not wearing indepence again boo boo boo
you said if you be the catch
I'll be the belle of pain you'll be the
match i'ma be a fuse Oh pain a baby of
to be the fuse I'm gonna put baby you
comedic news you me the singer oh what
is going on you dingleberries this has
nothing to do with this video but I got
a friend back in high school now used to
get mad at our friend Preston because he
used to make fun of him cuz he had
dingleberries I don't know how the topic
came up but he asked him if he watched
his [ __ ] and he said no some
president called him dingleberries for
like a couple months you have no other
use for this information do you now
we're working out and living a healthier
lifestyle there are times and you will
get discouraged yes it's bound to happen
because as you all know changing that
habit or even a lifestyle is a very
difficult thing to do so if you ever had
a friend that just looked you in the eye
and said it's easy just do it I want you
to do me a favor get a fourth throw it
in the oven and when it gets really hot
take it out and stab that [ __ ] in his
eyes listen don't tell someone that a
habit that they've developed for years
it's easy to break because you aren't
lying them and I'm not gonna lie to you
when I give you advice I'll do a
straight Korean parodies down I'll give
it to you real son right is like a pee
box of chocolate sometimes it's a poison
listen I know this sounds cliche but no
matter how hard it is you just gotta
push through it
I never choice because it's a penis joke
whatever dude don't judge me the reason
being is because a lot of us expect our
results to come through in an instant
we're so used to getting [ __ ] quick when
we want it and how we want it but let me
tell you something your body is not like
that in the most simple way possible I'm
gonna tell it to you like this you've
got to stop being stupid and changing
your diet for a couple of days it's
gonna suddenly make your three Chin's
magically disappear [ __ ] this is
a life change not Photoshop [ __ ] I said
this before and I'll say it again it
took years for you to get the way you
are now so it's going to take time for
you to change it if anything think about
it like this you're being unfair to your
body asking you to just change out of
nowhere when you've been treating it
like [ __ ] for years how do you like it
or somebody came up to you
and asked you to do a backflip over a
bed of hot coals when you've never done
the back lit before bet you tell that
[ __ ] to eat a second dump you
fart wouldn't you consistency is key my
friends and if you're Asian you should
already know about consistency
we built the [ __ ] Great Wall of China
you have any idea how hard-working and
consistent we had to be to build that
[ __ ] huh [ __ ] died in there god
damn listen I'm not here to lie to you
it's gonna be difficult but what you're
going to accomplish at the end is going
to be worth it why because you're worth
it so for the past couple weeks I talked
about a couple powerless movements
squats and deadlifts now for those of
you who aren't into going to gyms or
lifting weights trust me there are a lot
of alternatives so the workout for this
week is hiking now what it's Hocking us
hiking to me is just walking at an
incline right now I know a lot of you
out there my think well hiking is not
really a workout well [ __ ] you
and you really never hiked before hiking
[ __ ] difficult you're walking up in
an incline at a very consistent pace and
if you do it for a couple of miles the
amount of calories that you're burning
is you know pretty amazing working out
this in hack to be defined in a gym it's
any kind of activity that you can do
that'll get you off your ass the reason
why I personally like hiking is tiring
as [ __ ] it gets you out in the fun and
also it's a group activity so when you
need support people can be there to push
you along the way I kid you not the
first time I hide quickly I questioned
if I was gonna make it I lied underneath
the bush and there was like 17 vultures
looking at me like they were gonna have
like Thanksgiving dinner or some [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you see so remember buddy
fat bit BAM light is always what you
make it but it's up to you to take what
you deserve
let's go for broke yes that concludes
another episode of funny fat
I want McDonald's so yes as you guys
know I lost that initial 20 pounds but
now I'm trying to go even further
not so much in weight loss per se but in
turn the tracking what I'm doing with
exercise and also with my dietary needs
I am tracking everything that I'm eating
and every time I work out now so as I
gained more knowledge this knowledge
will be passed on to you to help you
guys along your way so thank you guys
for that support and once again if you
want to cut you get you already knows
that go for broke apparel calm this
shirt went out but if you guys want
certain designs out again I don't know
maybe I'll put it down again maybe if
you don't want it I don't know but yes
Bama we'll see you guys this Sunday it
might be a schedule up your vlog I don't
know but make sure you guys check me out
on Sunday and of course funny fact that
we've back then Wednesday after see
y'all then what's up disappear smoke
bomb then disappear that ninja to that
haha there are times that you will get
discouraged I just bit my tongue
everything yes it's bound to happen
because as you all may well know is that
even as you all may well know breaking
the habit that they've development
evidence that indicated a bit of need to
be today
listen don't tell someone that in my
opinion when you mislead someone and
what they're going to expect you're
setting them up for failure because oh
the reason why this is true for me is
because I don't know why is it you damn
it once you explain to these
[ __ ] goddamn it